what an honor it is to honor this
particular gentleman of course we know
him for all his great performances in so
many movies we also remember him as the
voice of Darth Vader and the voice of
CNN and it may come as a surprise as it
did to me to tell you of a story that
James told me about growing up because
for eight years he virtually did not
speak and he sucked because he suffered
from such a terrible stutter that in
contrast to the voice that we now know
as a child it was my dream not to direct
movies but to play the violin I wanted
to play the violin because it seemed
that that instrument was by far the most
expressive capable of conveying the
widest possible a range of emotions and
I guess getting to the heart of the
matter well that dream never did come
true for me for some reason my parents
sent me to play rugby but 20 years ago I
came as close as I ever could to making
that dream come true because in 1991 for
the first time and later many years
later I was lucky enough to direct James
Earl Jones and it was James Earl Jones
who was totally in control of the
instrument that is his acting skill I
used to call him the Stradivarius of
film actors working with him everything
was possible the only limitation was
imposed by one's own imagination and for
an Australian director fresh off the
flying kangaroo from Sydney it really
was a dream come true to be handed him
as an actor in patriot games I didn't
cast him that had been done before me
for The Hunt for Red October by my
friend mace neufeld and who sends his
love and his love to James
but back to those violin lessons working
with James on those two movies was
memorable for not being memorable at all
by that I mean that all the drama was in
front of the camera not behind the
camera we shot our scene so quickly
remarkably easy with a minimum of fuss a
maximum of choice to the director later
in the editing room and James taught me
so many things first of all that film
acting is about banking a whole host of
possibilities of performance
possibilities that an actor as much as a
director is a storyteller he understood
he either from experience or just
instinct that the director and actor
enjoy a symbiotic relationship that
we're totally dependent on each other
and as a director one felt completely
empowered by him personally and by his
performance he just energized you with
this calming strength of his presence
and he just filled you with confidence
in whatever you were doing if you really
did feel like you had the power and
afterwards when I got into the editing
room that was when I really appreciated
the gift that James had delivered to me
every take was first and foremost
utterly real and and human and then
after three or four takes you realized
he had left you was simply a mountain of
possibilities as a storyteller without
quite realizing it you the director had
become the equivalent of a great violin
player with a performance that had all
the light the shade and emotion that
that instrument could ever yield so I'd
like to say thank you to James for being
an inspiration
and a teacher to us all and also to
offer my congratulations for this Oscar
that he so rightly deserves
you